cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
take a look at this from CNN
as we get started with the story White
House sends letter to news execs urging
Outlets to ramp up scrutiny of gop's
Biden impeachment inquiry based on lies
I just want to stress
Oliver Darcy is a deeply evil individual
how do I know this I know Oliver Darcy
I've talked to him on many occasions
he's interviewed me on a variety of
stories there I I do not believe it
reasonable that Oliver Darcy is unaware
of what's going on politically I think
he's more than well aware uh of course
this is the guy who wrote the story
the reason why I say he's evil here's
the opening paragraph
the White House sent a letter to top U.S
news Executives on Wednesday urging them
to intensify their scrutiny of House
Republicans after speaker Kevin McCarthy
launched an impeachment inquiry into
President Joe Biden comma despite having
found no evidence of a crime let's just
pause right there and I'll break down
for you the psychotic depraved evil
manipulations of these people like
Oliver Darcy he is what I would describe
as like
um
uh how I just I think I think malicious
evil is a good way to describe it why
first if you are telling someone
something happened there is no reason
for you to insert a non-sequitur fact to
frame the story that's poisoning the
well adding despite having found no
evidence of a crime is immaterial to an
impeachment inquiry an inquiry is quite
literally an investigation we do not
typically
launch an indictment against an
individual and then investigate we
investigate and then indict impeachment
is indictment meaning Kevin McCarthy has
said there is a preponderance of
evidence of wrongdoing we're going to
begin an investigation to determine
whether or not this Rises to the level
of impeachment if it does we will vote
for impeachment inserting that sentence
into the into the article is a lie
there's a tremendous amount of evidence
cited by Kevin McCarthy and Republicans
reported by the New York Times by
Politico by The Wall Street Journal and
these crackpot and even CNN and so it's
these crackpot evil people at NBC News
at the AP and at CNN who are trying to
insert lies to shift the political
narrative there is no reason for that
sentence to be in this article because
you do not need evidence of a crime for
an inquiry you need a you need probable
cause
now again we do have evidence of a crime
and he's lying about there being no
evidence which is fascinating but the
big story here outside of the fact that
the Press is evil and most of them are
not all of them but the corporate press
the enemy the people the big story here
is the White House in pure desperation
just sent a demand letter to the Press
saying scrutinize this
WOW in what in what reality is the is
the federal government
here's what you do you send a CIA or FBI
guy to the journals and tell them to do
it on Open Letter shows they have lost
control do you have the copy of the
letter to get leaked no just uh we don't
even know who all they said I mean
there's their statements from it uh
spokesman spokesperson talked about it
but this is uh widely reported across
the board that they did this it sounds
like the um there's no proof or or
there's no evidence claim is the the
cover that they're running I've been
hearing this popping up the Noah by the
way if you ever talk about Hunter no
evidence no evidence even my mom told me
there's no evidence I'm like why why
would you why would you say there is or
isn't either way how do you know if
there is or isn't like she must have
been hearing this on TV yes yes 100
primer that's why Oliver Darcy is an
evil piece of trash because what he is
doing is inserting something immaterial
to an inquiry so that people like your
mom say there's no evidence though and
you know what you say to your mom you'd
be like well why would they have the
evidence before the investigation what
do you mean exactly well they're doing
an impeachment but with no evidence no
they're doing an invest investigation to
see to find the evidence yeah well I I
was just telling her about hunter's
stuff with barisma and she was like but
there's no evidence and I was like I
don't have 20 minutes
there's bank accounts have transfers
there's a lot of money though that's the
problem is that they've stonewalled most
of that information online it's been a
Legacy Media blackout and they do that
on purpose because again if they make
sure that the only people that know
about it are the politically initiated
you automatically when the headline
drops that oh a baseless impeachment
inquiry is taking place 90 of people are
going to believe it because think about
how many people you can tell about the
hunter Biden laptop from hell and
they're like wait what what that exists
did you know that uh Hunter Biden said
his dad takes his salary well I don't
know about that did you see the video
where Joe Biden said he went to Ukraine
to get a pro the prosecutor
investigating his unfired and he
threatened to withhold congressionally
approved loan guarantees I've never seen
that video yeah we get it yeah you've
never seen the videos
this is the purpose of they always do
this they'll say Donald Trump comma
without evidence comma claim here's my
favorite one
there was an article from CNN that was
ragging on Trump for uh claiming that
Joe Biden ordered his prosecution and
they said that it was a conspiratorial
claim or something despite the New York
Times quite literally having reported it
the New York Times reported we've quoted
it like five times this week already
that Joe Biden said he wanted Donald he
told his staff he wants Donald Trump
prosecuted for January 6th and he wants
Merrick Garland to stop acting like a
ponderous judge and be decisive
like what more do you need it's that is
him saying arrest him parallel realities
yeah and and then you get so this is
what happens the New York Times reports
it Trump hears it Trump speaks at a
rally and says and CR and crooked Joe is
to prosecute me telling telling mayor
Garland to do it and then when he says
it CNN writes Trump pushed a conspiracy
theory that Biden ordered his arrest
that's what they did all throughout
throughout his first term Trump would
read the news and then repeat what they
said and then they would reverse what
they said to this day people still tell
us that Trump said he was wanted people
to inject bleach into their veins so
we've seen this literally crazy to this
day people still run that line a lot of
them the Santa supporters no no shade on
them but you know hey obligatory
reference there you go right the the
fascinating thing about the DeSantis
phenomenon considering I think at this
point it's just like there isn't one the
Santa says immaterial you know uh I'll
I'll say this
fact if we if we run a segment on
DeSantis it basically just vanishes no
one even cares what's going on with this
campaign anymore but yeah but I still
see his prominent you know surrogates
and personalities saying things like
everyone I talk to says to Santos is is
the one we need and I'm like yeah okay
okay like that's just not true at all
because when I talk to people who have
concerns about Trump they're saying
Vivek ramaswamy I get it there's a lot
of polling for tennis still and Vivek
has had said a few moments where he
surpassed DeSantis but DeSantis remains
you know in the principle position after
Trump but I've I've I've we've gone all
over the place I was in Portland Maine I
was in the Outer Banks I've not
experienced this DeSantis he's the real
like I see Trump Flags everywhere you
know that's uh that kind of takes me
back to why they're doing all this to
Trump and why DeSantis refuses to drop
out because again they're trying to tank
the well right now you're going to have
an impeachment inquiry against Joe Biden
if they have to kick Joe Biden I'll be
in you know again they want to do it
where he's riding off the defense Sunset
you know saying oh his Health's just bad
and he just doesn't want to hold up the
office no we're going to stay in with an
impeachment but the thing is if they
kick Trump off of the ballots and do
that they need somebody else to stay in
in the second place and that's why even
though he's losing even though he's
predicted to lose Iowa their tempering
expectations on Iowa they're you know
DeSantis is he's still staying in stuff
differently even though they're
literally blowing through money and so
this media scrutiny on this impeachment
is basically kind of walking it all down
you know you gotta you gotta kind of uh
taint the wells public opinion you
already know you're probably going to
have enough to impeach not enough to
remove so you don't want Joe Biden to be
impeached and then resigned because of
the impeachment and it looks like okay
this guy was like a stone cold Criminal
that's what you don't want so they're
trying to you know again tank dwell
think public reception and then get
Trump out of there now we've got what is
it four states where there are lawsuits
to remove Trump I think so you've got
Colorado Oklahoma Minnesota and Florida
and then Arizona they entertained it but
the secretary of state was like I can't
do this New Hampshire there was a debate
but these four states there are lawsuits
my question is
where are the lawsuits to remove Joe
Biden from the ballot under the 14th
Amendment for being an insurrectionist
did Donald Trump get convicted in a
criminal court of being an
insurrectionist no so why are they
filing lawsuits right now ah in their
opinion Donald Trump saying peacefully
protest warrants Insurrection in my
opinion Joe Biden ordering his attorney
general to arrest his political rival is
an Insurrection against our our
institutions and our Constitution and as
such
I think he should be ineligible to run
for president they should have his name
removed from the ballot where are any it
should actually be removed from office
immediately so where are any of the
lawsuits from the right challenging Joe
Biden being on the ballot you're gonna
certainly worded letters come on don't
we all just love those sternly words
I promise he might even use a wordy nerd
in there and then you know really make
it stink but uh no this is exactly what
we're talking about they will remove
Trump's name from the ballot I I will I
will say this there is in my mind a 95
chance that in some form Trump's name is
removed from the ballot somewhere why
in in Arizona they printed the wrong
sized ballot on the wrong sized paper
and jammed up all the machines what I
expect to happen at the very last minute
and uh so October of next year maybe
when the ballots are being sent out
batches of them will not have Trump's
name on it and then someone in the off
in these offices Secretary of State or
otherwise will say Trump is an
insurrectionist it's not in dispute so I
removed his name under the 14th
Amendment they will be sued and then
come December the Supreme Court will say
hey you can't do that and they'll say
okay we can't we'll put his name back
post Ace oh he lost by the way um that's
how it always goes man but I mean this
is what's happening you've got
ideological capture in the uh judicial
field you know in in the court of law
all your lawyers are coming out they're
literally left-leaning your judges are
left-leaning it's literally becoming to
the point where they can do whatever the
heck they want and then you know you
have conservatives we're over here
telling our kids oh no no don't go to
college go go get a trade you know our
kids they're just uh you know our boys
are young boys are like okay I'll go be
an electrician because all they want is
just little money they want to chase it
and get some puniti on the side so
they're like you know I'm just gonna go
where the money is but then your
institutions are completely captured and
they're left-leaning and all the legal
interpretations of this whole immutable
Constitution are all turned against you
and this is kind of the problem that we
face it's like even if we win 2024
because of how the law is because of how
they're doing these counties you're not
guaranteed to even have a lasting
Victory because our feeder system our
farm system is all screwed up
yeah true abject corruption across the
country and unfortunately
the people who believe in this country
believe in its rules and its morals and
its ethics and the people who don't
which is don't and they cheat that goes
to the point that I made the other day
about how liberals need to understand
that you can only be a liberal and I'm
talking about classical liberals
classical liberals need to understand
that you can only be a liberal with
other liberals yep unfortunately you
cannot be a liberal and engage with
fascists you cannot be in a liberal and
engage with with authoritarians like
marxists and stuff because they don't
hold the same values that liberals do if
you don't think honesty is important
then you'll manipulate words and change
the meaning so that way you can just get
what your way that's the point if if we
were dealing with liberals you wouldn't
have people trying to manipulate the
words that we're using to describe ideas
right the point of manipulating the
words is to circumvent the actual law if
you were a liberal then you would say
well I'm going to honestly present my
case and if your case is better than my
case we're looking to collaborate on an
idea and produce a better result for
people so what we're going to do is
collaborate blah blah blah if you are if
you're not looking for that if you're
just looking for power then you'll
manipulate you'll twist words you'll do
whatever you can liberals need to
understand when you're dealing with
authoritarians liberalism doesn't work
do you think it works with corporatism
at all I don't I don't understand your
question well I feel like corporations
the most fascist aspect of our society
the collusion with the government so
like I've always thought that I have
some liberal Vestige in me but I've been
born and raised in this corporatocracy
and I just kind of play along I send
taxes to the War Machine and so like am
I even do we even have any liberalism in
this Society I want to think that I do
the problem is liberalism in having any
sort of liberal Society creates a vacuum
of which authoritarians can use to take
power you know they always say you vote
yourself into tyranny but then you gotta
your way out again I'm not going to say
the other one because that apparently
that's incitement these days but uh so
it was a corporate pain is that just
like the the economist's way to create
authoritarianism legally so it's illegal
corporatism
legally is a cartel system and that's
the thing it's not capitalism it's
corporatism they are they've used
corporatism as a weapon multiple times
you know we can go back to how we tried
to collapse Russia and we literally
brought their life expectancy of the
average Russian male down to 50 you know
somewhere in the mid 50s using
corporatism the cash for vouchers
program the you know the where they were
basically converting the command economy
into a capitalist society and they gave
starving Russians who needed medicine
and food vouchers and these vouchers
weren't ever on you know they they were
never honored so they gave them all of
that and then they then you know you got
these Western firms these corporate talk
you know these kleptocrats coming in
working with oligarchs who had the money
and saying hey we need you to buy up
these shares and they use corporatism
they bought up all the economy and
basically used that and then I ended
their weapon thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time